it is great to be joined today by Nicole
Murphy who's the daughter of Paul
Kingston leader of the Kingston group
and profit and presiding priesthood of
the LDS Church is author of the leaders
daughter where to even start at this
point Nicole I mean it that your story
is so interesting maybe we can just give
our audience an overview of sort of the
religious upbringing that you were born
into and then maybe that will get us
talking about polygamy Mormonism and
everything else that's in your past
all right ready when you are
yeah no go ahead so so I mean were you
what what religion were you born into I
was born into so there's a there's the
mainstream Mormonism and then there's
the break off of the fundamentalist
Mormon Mormonism and I'm from the break
off where they live polygamy they live
consecration and they live the original
Mormon doctrine whereas the mainstream
has let some of those original
principles go a little bit do you know
at what point there was this kind of
separation where what we would consider
kind of like the modern Mormon Mormon
Church stopped adhering to some of those
original principles yeah in 1890 then
Utah was trying to become a state and
the problem that they were running into
is the government didn't like polygamy
and so they had to sign the 1890
manifesto that stopped all polygamous
marriages
it didn't just it doesn't didn't disavow
the ones that were already in practice
but it did prevent new ones from
happening and then in the 1900s then
that's when they said no more pointless
marriages and they stopped everything
and what was sort of the dynamic of your
father's role within the Mormon Church
but also that this sort of offshoot so
my father was that I've never actually
in the mainstream Mormon Church his
grandfather started the started my group
in 1935 and my father was born into it
and what were some of the
characteristics of that subgroup so that
some group lives consecration where they
believe everything is turned into the
church and the church decides how
everything is is used all the resources
and everything fact it's a lot like
communism and then they also live
polygamy which is more than one life so
in thinking about your childhood you
were born into this
yeah it's first of all what what
percentage of them let's actually let me
even back up how big is this subgroup
and what percentage of that group is
living the polygamous lifestyle um
there's about 5,000 people and I would
say I would say 90% of them are living
polygamy and when you talk about living
polygamy we're talking about how many
wives in general my dad had 27 now
that's a lot for one man even in my own
group in fact the next one I know of is
his brother who have 15 most of them
have three or four or five the leaders
all tend to have more wives but the ones
most of the followers have two or three
and when you were growing up I mean at
what age did you realize that most of
the world in the United States is not
polygamous I was actually so my dad had
me in a public school for kindergarten
and first grade and then he pulled us
out and put us into his own school and
then at that point we weren't allowed to
socialize with anybody outside of our
community and so it wasn't until I was
in my teens 14 15 years old nine
graduated high school and I had gone to
college that I realized that this wasn't
normal
and when you were growing up did you
literally believe the other than the
lifestyle stuff were you sort of like a
literal believer in the doctrine and
teachings of Mormonism that were part of
your upbringing um actually I I believed
in all of it when I was younger in fact
when I was 12 years old I planned on
being a second third or fourth wife I
believed in all of it until I until I
got much older and started seeing diff
and the outside opinions and the order
opinions the order is the name of the
group I come from and I just started
seeing all the differences and I
realized how wrong how wrong the
polygamy part was that's interesting so
it was the polygamy part specifically
that was like the first thing that
struck you as something is not right
here yeah I watched my mom live the
lifestyle and I watched her
buuuut I watched her very unhappy for a
lot of years and it really broke my
heart and it wasn't until I I had
actually spoken with other wives that
were also very unhappy that I realized
that it wasn't a happy lifestyle can you
talk a little bit about you said you
were on your way or thought you would
become a second third or fourth wife
what's the significance within the group
of being a first wife versus like a
subsequent wife the first wife is
usually the prettiest the one that is
capable of running the family I guess or
the one that is gonna run away if she
doesn't get to be first time and were
you starting to be sort of groomed in
this direction when you were I don't
know a kid a teenager like what starts
to be the preparation for being part of
that I feel like you're kind of groomed
from birth you're taught in your prayers
and I mean at two three years old you're
taught to say your prayers and find the
person that God wants you to marry and
then it goes up you have marriage
classes starting from age 12 I your
groom pretty much from birth to be the
spiritual life that they want you to be
and our they're people that resist or is
it basically total cultish groupthink
and and the sort of resistors are pretty
few and far between the resistors are
pretty few and far between in fact I'm
only the fifth of my father's 200 plus
children that have left I mean it's not
a couple leaves sense to me but the
majority of them stay and believe in the
community and when you have 200 kids do
you even know all of them do you
remember the names of all of them like
what are the logistics of that I don't
think he does
I would say that he does not remember
that all the names and just doing kind
of math I mean I'm just we're gonna get
into the sort of philosophical elements
of leaving but just from math if you
have 20-something wives are you spending
like a day a month with each of them or
what what's the day-to-day life of a
polygamist my dad my dad hasn't yeah you
got to keep in mind my dad has more
wives than most but he came home once
every two or three months and it was
usually around birthdays and
anniversaries that he was home and then
went and then when my mom had a night
every 2 or 3 months and he would come
home for that Wow I mean that's just
that that that is that is incredible so
talk a little bit about when you started
to sort of consider that this may not be
the place for you and kind of seriously
start to think about leaving I had a lot
of sexual assault growing up as a child
and so that kind of put me into a state
of depression where I felt like I felt
like there was something not right I
didn't know what it was but I knew that
there was something wrong with
everything going on and so that kind of
planted the first seeds and then as I
got older and I went to college and I
started seeing different different
points of view there was a lot of racism
in my group and I had a really hard time
with that there was it's a very sexist
community and I had a really hard time
with that as well so it just it just
little seeds were planted along the way
to kind of lead me astray I guess talk a
little bit about that so let maybe let's
take the racism part first like in what
in what ways was this a racist room so
they originally taught that black people
have an extra bone in their body that
kind of goes to show and then you're not
allowed to socialize with anybody of
color you're not allowed to marrying
anybody of color and that actually seems
I mean at one point that was sort of a
mainstream Mormon belief wasn't it that
they have backed off of over the last
several decades absolutely in fact it
wasn't until the 70s that that black
people could hold the priesthood in the
mainstream Mormon
they're still not even close to that and
point me and then as far as the the
sexism part can you talk a little bit
about the ways that that manifested
women are pretty much just a tool
they're not really people where I come
from they're just a tool to for a guy to
get to heaven interesting and in terms
of roles within the community are there
when it comes even down to like jobs and
that type of thing I mean is it is it
that's specifically outlined what it is
that women are allowed to do they're
pretty much just told to do whatever
their husband tells them to some
husbands will want their wives to work
to bring in income some wives will have
to stay home with the kids
and it just depends on whatever the
husband what role the husband wants her
to play in that family and it's it
really it really just is up to the
husband and how he governs his own
family so you start to develop a plan to
get out what what do you do how do you
think about it honestly I took it one
day at a time it was really a struggle
to even wrap my mind around the fact
that I was going to leave and I kind of
I kind of knew that it was coming but I
didn't I couldn't really wrap my mind
around what it meant
yeah and so it really was just I made a
plan and I put that plan into place and
I kind of just put one foot in front of
the other and then finally I realized I
was out and just and it just snowballs
from there I got a job I did have a lot
of help in fact I had a sensei that I
was really close to and he really just
helped me put a plan into place and say
okay this is what an adult does on the
outside world and I mean you've got to
get a job maybe start saving some money
you better have a car and he really
helped me put the logistics into place
and kind of helped me make a plan to
follow and Nicole when you say you had a
sensei are you using that word in the
sense of like this was a martial arts
teachers that have a different different
meaning that you're using no he really
was a martial arts teacher I don't know
if maybe like within the within this
group their sensei it means something
else so who did you tell in
advance of leaving and nobody I couldn't
in fact about three months before I left
then I sat down with my two closest
friends and I told them this is the
choice that I'm making and I still love
you and I'm still here for you but I can
no longer stay in this community and one
of my friends asked me she said will you
wait until my wedding because if I left
before her wedding I would not be
allowed to attend and so I agreed I
waited until her wedding and I was one
of her bridesmaids and then after that
point then I that's when I left
do you I mean say as much or as little
about this as you want but if you still
live in physical proximity to where your
family is or have you moved very far I
haven't I've moved probably about thirty
minutes away from the majority of them
so it's not super far but it's not
they're not in my backyard and do did
you receive any contact from people
initially and are you still in contact
with people from your family a lot of my
full siblings I've kept in contact with
some of them have married into the
community and have become second turned
wives and they're not allowed to speak
to me but a lot of for the majority I'm
I do keep in contact with my full
siblings my mom and I struggled but yeah
I mean Izzy so is she I guess first
question is it strictly speaking is she
forbidden from having contact with you
um she was initially not necessarily
forbidden but very strongly discouraged
and my siblings were all forbidden to
have contact with me for a long time but
then after they became 18 and and my dad
kind of realized that you know they he
didn't really have as much control over
them but a lot of my siblings are also
forbidden from talking to some of the
people that are still in the community
because they talked to me so there is
that control in that aspect as well can
you talk a little bit about the ways in
which the organization the group exerts
control over people and whether that's
physical controllers
psychological control and sort of like
what you had to break through in order
to get out what are the tactics that
they use um it really is more mental
control than anything as far as physical
control my dad tried to prevent me from
buying a car he took my money so I
wasn't allowed to as soon as he realized
what I was doing he took my money and I
wasn't allowed to take any more of my
money that I had earned so as far as he
does things like that physically but a
lot of it really is mental and emotional
control I mean if you leave you're not
allowed to see your family you're
considered the devil an apostate or
whatever they whatever word they use for
it now but they just it really is more
mental and emotional control when you
talked about the fact that there was
sexual abuse is is in general is there
significant physical abuse used either
like as a discipline tool or to ensure
compliance yes so my dad when I was six
years old he actually beat me with a
piece of a bed as after his brother went
to prison for third-degree child abuse I
think it was felony child abuse if I
remember right
after he went to prison for that then a
lot of them stopped using such harsh
abuse tactics more because they were
afraid of going to prison but they do
still use very abusive tactics the last
thing I want to ask you about in the
limited time we have is in the United
States polygamy strictly speaking is
against the law so can you talk a little
bit about how that is circumvented and
and and sort of how they have this
de-facto polygamy even though it is
against the law the way that they get
around it is he doesn't actually marry
the subsequent wives he'll get a
marriage certificate for the first one
and then the second and third and fourth
it's just a spiritual ceremony so
technically there's really no way to
prove that they're living polygamy
because there's no paper show got it
pretty straightforward in fact yeah the
book is incredible we've been speaking
with Nicole Murphy who's the author of
the leaders daughter she is the daughter
of
Kingston leader of the Kingston group
and profit and presiding priesthood of
the LDS Church Nicole thank you so much
for talking to me today
thank you so much for having me it's
been a pleasure